une journée pour vous ressourcer c'était
le thème d'entrée dans village à Plaisir
plusieurs points d'information étaient
organisés dont un comptoir des aidans
animé par le pôle autonomie territoire
de Versailles SaintQuentin en iveline on
va s'occuper plus précisément des
personnes âgées et des personnes en
situation de handicap la MDPH et donc
les personnes alors que ce soit les
aidés ou les aidants viennent dans nos
services pour avoir des information un
événement qui relève parfois d'une
grande importance pour les prochesdents
on dit ce n'est pas toi qui est malade
c'est lui ou elle mais on a du mal à
réellement se mettre dans la place de l'
dents et du coup la reconnaissance de
l'idents est vraiment important à
l'heure actuelle parce queil y en a de
plus en plus les aides à domicile les
association c'est bien mais quelque part
quand on voit les problématiques qu'on
peut rencontrer au niveau des aides à
domicile ça peut être compliqué et nous
donner davantage de travail des ateliers
ludiques ont été organisés comme les
débats théâtres ou encore les ateliers
de cuisine pour s'évader parler des
problématiques que peuvent avoir les
participants sur un manque d'appétit par
exemple sur le fait de devoir enrichir
les repas sur un manque d'idée en fait
aussi dans dans les repas donc c'est un
atelier un petit peu interactif avec
voilà qui va mêler le fait de faire
soi-même c'est que c'est pas moi qui
fait les recettes ce sont les
participants qui font les recettes
prochain événement mercredi 18 octobre
un café entrédent aura lieu à la Maison
de voisinage de coignère vous vousê